اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض التي
نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار وملات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
يؤكد ان الحلف لا يستبعد سقوط بخموت بيد
الروس قريبا
زخم سياسي ودبلوماسي لقاءات سعوديه يمنيه
بولنديه في الرياض وتاكيد على الاستقرار
العالمي
الرياض تجمع 100 منظمه استشراف واقع
التعليم والثقافه ودعوات لتكامل ثقافي
عالمي
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه تتابعون
ايضا
شهر كامل على الكارثه عيادات مركز الملك
سلمان تواصل اغاثه متضرر الزلزال شمال
سوريا
[موسيقى]
تمكين مستمر للسيدات السعوديات الرابعه
تعايش مجندات وزاره الدفاع من التدريب الى
التخرج
اهلا بكم قال الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسي يانس انه لا يستبعد سقوط ضخموت
خلال الايام مشيرا الى ضروره عدم انعكاس
ذلك الى نقطه التحول في الحرب
تناول العكس
الاسابيع والاشهر الاخيره نرى قتالا شرسا
في باخموت روسيا تلقي بالمزيد من القوات
وما تفتقده من المهارات العسكريه تعوضه
بكميات القوات عانوا من خسائر كبيره ولكن
في الوقت نفسه لا يمكن استبعاد ان بخموت
ستسقط في النهايه خلال الايام المقبله لذا
من المهم ان لا ينعكس ذلك الى نقطه تحول
في الحرب وهو ايضا يؤكد ضروره عدم
الاستهانه بروسيا في هذا السياق تتجه
اوروبا لتعزيز مخزون الاسلحه والذخيره في
اوكرانيا هذا ما شدد عليه مسؤول الشؤون
الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جاسف بارل حيث
اكد على ضروره منح الاولويه في الانفاق من
الصناديق الاوروبيه لزياده انتاج الذخيره
لصالح اوكرانيا واشار بورال قبيل اجتماع
وزراء الدفاع الاتحاد الاوروبي الى ضروره
تعزيز الصناعات الدفاعيه والعسكريه في
اوروبا وتبني ذلك كهدف لضمان الامن
ميدانيا ومع اشتداد القتال في مدينه باخمت
الاستراتيجيه شرق اوكرانيا بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه نقل المكتب الاعلامي
لمؤسس شركه فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه قوله
ان قواته سيطرت بشكل كامل على القسم
الشرقي لمدينه باخموت مؤكدا ان كل ما يقع
شرق نهر المدينه باتل الان تحت سيطره قوه
وينضم الينا من كياف مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بك حذيفه يعني هل من تعليقات
اوكرانيه حتى الان حول تصريحات
بانه لا يستبعد سقوط باخموت بيد الروس
قريبا
تحياتي راويه كل عام وانت وجميع الزميلات
في شبكه العربيه والنساء العالم بخير
في الحقيقه فيما يخص تصريحات
فيما يخص تصريحات في ستوكهولم لدى لقائه
بوزراء دفاع الدول الاوروبيه لم تذهب
بعيدا ايضا عن تصريحات وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
يعني كانت قبل يومين حول ضخمه يبدو ان
شركائكيف ينظرون الى ان باخ متوك وكانوا
قد نصحوا طبعا كيف من قبل الانسحاب من هذه
المدينه ولكن القياده العسكريه والسياسيه
في اوكرانيا ترى ان هذا هدف استراتيجي
بالنسبه لها وانها لن تنسحب من هذه
المدينه طبعا كانوا قد برروا ذلك بكلفه
الباهظه
للتمسك بالمدينه في الزخائر وايضا في
القوات يعني الجميع هناك يفقد اعداد كبيره
من الجنود وكذلك تصرف اوكرانيا عدد هائل
من الذقائر حتى الان لم تعلق القياده
الاوكرانيه حول هذه التصريحات ولكن بشكل
عام اوكرانيا متمسكه بالبقاء في باقي
وتنظر اليك هدف استراتيجي سوف
كامل على القسم الشرقي لمدينه باخمت ماذا
عن الروايه الاوكرانيه
نعم اوكرانيا ما زالت تقول ان المدينه تحت
سيطرتها بالكامل ولكن ضواحي المدينه
بالفعل هنالك زحف روسي وهنالك اختراق
للدفاعات لذلك هي تراجعت قليلا وعززت من
دفاعاتها وقامت ببناء دفاعات الهندسيه
للحفاظ على الجبهات خاصه الجبهه الشماليه
والجبهه جنوب شرق المدينه كذلك في اتجاهكا
واتجاه ماريكا حيث كانت القوات الروسيه
تحاول الاختراق بشكل كبير
ايضا ادلى بتصريح لشبكه سي ان ان بخصوص
مدينه باقمت وبرر قراره بالبقاء في الباك
والحفاظ على هذه الجبهه وقال ان هذا هدف
استراتيجي بالنسبه لنا لن نسمح اي سقوط او
او سقوط ضخمه سيسمح بمزيد من التقدم قد
يفتح الطريق للسيطره على مدن رئيسيه
واساسيه في الدونيس كذلك الهدف
الاستراتيجي الاخر بالنسبه للجيش
الاوكراني هو تدمير اكبر عدد من القوه
الروسيه لان القوه الروسيه
القت باعداد كبيره وهائله من الجنود ومن
المعدات والاليات والموارد في هذه الجبهه
بالتحديد وكذلك ايضا استنزاف القوات
الروسيه لان هذه هي الجبهه الرئيسيه الان
في القتال دونما جبهه اباخ موت هي جبهات
خامله هنالك عمليات قصف نعم ولكن عمليات
تقدم وتركيز من الاتحاد الروسي هي فقط في
هذه الجبهره حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه من
كاف شكرا جزيلا لك
اكد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على ان
موسكو تواجه تهديدات مباشره لامنها
وسيادتها لكنها في نفس الوقت تشهد استعداد
وجهوزيه الناس للدفاع عن المستقبل والدفاع
عن الحقيقه واضاف الرئيس الروسي ان هناك
العديد من الامثله على الشجاعه والحزم
والاستعداد لحمايه الناس والدفاع عن
الحقيقه وعن مستقبل بلادهم
افاد فريق تحقيق اتحاديا الماني بانه يجري
تفتيش سفينه مشتبه بها في انها نقلت
متفجرات على خلفيه حادثه نورت ستريم وبحسب
صحيفه ديدسايت الالمانيه ان محققين عثروا
على قارب استخدم لتفخيخ انابيب نور ستريم
اسفل بحر البلطيق وكان قد استاجره شخصان
اوكرانيا من شركه مقرها بولندا ولكن لم
يعثر المحققون بعد على الجهه التي امرت
بتنفيذ عمليه التفجير وبحسب التحقيقات نفذ
العمليه فريق كوماندوس اوكراني مؤلف من
سته اشخاص خمسه رجال وسيده ونقلوا
المتفجرات على القارب وابحروا من ميناء
روستوك بالمانيا في السادس من سبتمبر
الماضيه
كشفت تقارير صحفيه عن ان استخبارات الدول
الغربيه وجدت ما يدل على يد اوكرانيا في
عمليه التخريب التي طالت خطي انابيب غاز
ووفقا لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه فان حلف
شمال الاطلسي الناتو منع نشر هذه
المعلومات لان هذا من شانه ان يؤدي الى
تدهور العلاقات بين اوكرانيا والمانيا
وبحسب الصحيفه فان الاستخبارات الاوروبيه
تعرف اسم الراعي الخاص لعمليه التخريب وهو
اوكراني ثري يزعم انه لا تربطه علاقه
بالرئيس فلاديمير
نشره الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
منصه احسان السعوديه تطلق بوابه لكبار
المحسنين وتجمع ثلاثه مليارات ريال خلال
عمل
اهلا بكم من جديد زخم سياسي ودبلوماسي
سعودي كبير هذا الاسبوع بدا بلقاء ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان برئيس
مجلس القياده اليمني رشاد العليمي حملت
تاكيد على دعم الجهود للتوصل الى حل سياسي
شامل في اليمن برعايه امميه كما تشهد
الرياض زياره لرئيس وزراء بولندا ماتيوس
مورافسكي التقى فيها الامير محمد بن سلمان
استعرض خلالها سبلت تعاون الثنائي بين
الرياض وارسو وعلى صعيد النشاط الدبلوماسي
التقى وزير الخارجيه السعودي بنظيره
البريطاني في لندن الازمه الاوكرانيه
تصدرت عناوين هذه الزياره في ظل انباء عن
توجه الامير فيصل بن فرحان لروسيا ايضا في
زياره رسميه وفي الشرق الاسيوي وتحديدا
كوريا الجنوبيه بحث وزير الدفاع السعودي
الامير خالد بن سلمان التعاون العسكري
معصول والتقى خلال الزياره بالرئيس الكوري
يون سوكيول دلالات واسعه حملتها سياسه
السعوديه تجاه التطورات العالميه اهمها
التاكيد السعودي المستمر على المصالح
القوميه وربط استقرار العالمي بالتنميه
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اكد ان السعوديه منفتحه على الحوار
مع ايران مضيفا ان الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران ليس مثاليا ويجب ان يعالج مخاوف دول
الجوار واكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه انه
يوجد اجماع على ان الوضع في سوريا ليس
مقبولا وانه يوجد حوار لعوده سوريا الى
الحضن العربي لكن من المبكر الحديث عن ذلك
وحول الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه اكد
الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان موقف السعوديه
واضح واستقرار وامن الفلسطينيين مشيرا الى
انه توجد احتماليه لمواجهه عنف اكبر اذا
لم يتم حل القضيه الفلسطينيه ايضا اضاف
وزير الخارجي السعودي ان العلاقه مع البيت
الابيض جيده جدا كما ان الصين من اكبر
الحلفاء التجاريين للرياض كما هي مع باقي
العالم
[موسيقى]
وينضم اليه هنا في استديوهات الرياض
الكاتب الصحفي جاسر الجاسر اهلا بك معنا
سيد جاسر يعني دلالات هذا الزخم السياسي
والدبلوماسي من والى الرياض في هذا
التوقيت بالذات في ظل الصراع وتحديات
اقتصاديه وسياسيه كبرى
مساء الخير
الرياض عاصمه النشاط ليس فقط اقليميا
بالدوليا في هذا لكن ما نشهده اليوم هو
زخم ايضا مختلف في تحريك او في تعميق
الاستقرار في العالم يعني اليوم مثلا
استقبال الامير محمد وللعهد لرئيس وزراء
البولندي في هذه الجوله جانب منها مرتبط
بالتعاون الثنائي واعتقد ايضا جانب اخر
مرتبط ايضا في عمليه اعاده او صياغه
السلام في الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه نشهد
يعني زياره الامير فيصل فرحان لاوكرانيا
الاخبار شبه مؤكده او بطاريه على
الزياره الموسكو المملكه تتمتع فيها
الموقف لنجد في هذا في الجانب في القدره
او لعلها يمكن الدوله الوحيده التي تتمتع
بعلاقات قويه وثابته ومتينه وشراكه مع
الطرفين المتورطين في الازمه والعالقين في
الازمه وبالتالي هي الصوت مقبول لدى
الجميع ولذلك ممكن تحدث المملكه فرقا
اساسيا وجوهريا في تحقيق هذه المعادله
ولذلك ما يحدث اليوم انا اعتقد بدايات او
مؤشرات لنشاط سيتسع ويتطور في هذا الجانب
هذه حركه
نشطه على كافه المستويات في تحقيق هذا
العمل يعني لقاءات الامير فيصل فرحان مع
الوزراء الخارجيه الدول مجموعه العشرين
زياره بريطانيا كلها تصب في هذا السياق
اذا هناك ملفات المملكه تحرص عليها وتامل
عليها تحقيق الاستقرار والسلام في اليمن
العمل على معالجه الازمات في المنطقه في
العراق وسوريا والعراق وفلسطين ثاني
والمساهم الد في تحقيق الاستقرار العالمي
بما يضمن التنميه والاستقرار ومداد سلاسل
الامداد واليقين الذي تحمله المملكه في
السياسه الخارجيه ان الحرب لا تؤدي الى
المزيد من المشاكل والاعاقه والضرر لجميع
شعوب العالم وبالتالي لابد من البحث عن
خيارات اخرى لتقليص الفارق والوصول الى
نقطه السلام وهي تحمل هذا الملف سيد جاسر
تحدثت عن نقطه مهمه جدا هي ثبات موقف
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من قضايا كبرى
هذا ما يؤكده ربما حديث وزير الخارجيه
السعودي عندما تحدث عن الملف النووي
الايراني عن علاقات المملكه مع سوريا
وعودتها الى الحضن العربي وايضا العلاقات
مع البيت الابيض هذا الثبات في المواقف
كيف سيفتح طرقا ربما لحل لان تكون
السعوديه طرفا في حل ازمه اوكرانيا وغيرها
من الملفات اولا يعني الامير محمد بن
سلمان شخصيه يتمتع بعلاقات قويه ومتينه مع
جميع قاده العالم بشكل يعني يحظى بثقه
هؤلاء القاده وثقه الدول ويتعزز الثقه من
خلال رؤيه المملكه ثبات في السياسه
والرؤيه التنمويه في المملكه التي حققت
نتائج مذهله ومطوله جدا بالتالي عزت هذا
النمط وهذا الصوره والمرونه والتحرك
الكامل في المملكه مع جميع الاطراف يعني
اذا اخذنا الان في سياق تصريحات الامير
فيصل الامير فيصل تكلم عن نقطتين مثلا
علاقاتنا مع الصين قويه علاقاتنا مع البيت
الابيض قويه نعم نحن مفتحون على جميع
الاطراف لا لا
ماذا يحقق هذه الغايه الاساس اللي هو خدمه
مصالح المملكه اولا بدرجه اساسيه بمعزه
العلاقه مع طرف من الاطراف الخطوه الاخرى
التواصل مع جميع العالم بانفتاح وبدون
اشكالات ولان المملكه لا تنتمي الي محور
من المحاور بشكل واضح ومعين بالتالي هي
قمه مقبوله منفتحه لجميع الخيرات النقطه
الثالثه استمراريه التعاون والتعزيز هذه
القيمه بالتالي اليوم احنا في هذا الجانب
نعم البيت الابيض يعني انا اعتقد انه
التاكيد على البيت الابيض السعوديه
الامريكيه هي فيها تحصيل حاصل صحيح يعني
نجد انه في بعض الفتور في الجوانب
السياسيه في ملفات معينه وهذا طبيعي لكن
عمق ونوعيه وجذور الشراكه المتراس نحن
الرمال يعني مناورات الرمال الحمراء وهي
استعداد مثلا في الوجود ومتصله بيئه من
المنطقه نشرت التواصل والمستمر الداخل على
مستويات لكن ايضا حتى المستوى السياسي
يمكن بعض الشباب اللي كانت بدات تذوب الان
في الملف الايراني طبعا موقف المملكه يعني
من قديم موظف محدد ولا بد من الدخول فيه
لا بد من الوصول الى نتائج واضحه والتاكيد
بانه في حال حدوث خلل في هذا الملف او هو
استطاعت ايران الحصول على سلاح
نوويات الاخرى ولن تبقى منتظره او مراعاه
يعني مخاوف الدول المجاوره لماذا تكون
شريكه فيها لان اصلا يعني قضيه الملف
النووي هو متصل بالمنطقه اساسا وليس منتصر
بالخارج فغياب هذه الشراكه بالتالي تؤدي
ولذلك انا اعتقد المملكه نجحت خلال فتره
من الاتصالات الثنا مع الدول الخمس يد
واحد في هذا الجانب في تعديل كثير من
المتصله وبالتالي اليوم نشهد صحه موقف
المملكه من حاله الانهيار والقلق الاوروبي
صدر قبل قليل بيان فرنسي الماني بريطاني
على التشكيك والتاكيد على خلخله في الجانب
اذا جينا في الملف السوري ايضا المملكه
واضحه في الجانب نعم هي اولا اعاده القدره
على تحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه يؤكد على
التنميه والاستقرار المنطقه لابد ان تعيش
الاستقرار وهذه لابد من خلخله او انتزاع
الفتائل التي تؤدي الى هذا التوتر سوريا
ساحه مزعجه ومربكه وساحه الهيمنه
الايرانيه بشكل كبير اذا بالتالي هناك
ترحيب هناك قنوات فتحت هذه الدول التي
قامت علاقات مشهوره وسط سوريا هي تنقل هذه
الرسائل بالامكان هل تستطيع سوريا او
النظام في سوريا ان يقوم بالاجراءات
اللازمه لان يكون فعلا عضوا عربيا حقيقيا
في الجامعه العربيه هذه مؤشرات اذا الباب
مهد وفتح لهذا الجانب فالبقي الدور على
سوريا نفسها يتحرك وان تتحرر من هذه
الارتباطات المزعجه وان تعود ان تكون طرف
ستكون هناك امكانات اخرى ولذلك الاشاره
وصلت الرساله الى الجانب السوري وبقي
التحرك من جانب بما يخص زياره وزير الدفاع
السعودي الامير خالد بن سلمان الى كوريا
الجنوبيه اهميه هذه الزياره من الناحيه
الدفاعيه والتعاون العسكري
تتفق مبدئيا المملكه يعني وضعت استراتيجيه
لتوطين الصناعات العسكريه المملكه ليست
مجرد مشترين ليست مجرد سوق تعمل اليوم على
الاستفاده وتوطين التقنيه والصناعات
والشراكه فيها ولذلك العقود التي تحدث
اليوم والاتفاقات تبحث عن الخيارات التي
تلبي احتياجات المملكه والاطراف القادره
على التعاون في عمليه الصناعه يعني في
بريطانيا حتحقق مساله العمل او اتفاق
النوايا بشان القدرات الجويه المستقبليه
وهذه المرحله المهمه في التصنيع والمشاركه
في التصنيع والتوطين وليس فقط شراء او كذا
فهذه النقطه اليوم في كوريا ايضا في
الجانب ونجد انه حتى يعني الرئيس الكوري
الامير خالد بن سلمان في هذا الجانب يوضح
انه هناك تعاون عميق جدا وهو تعاون يعني
لو ناخذه في مسارات اخرى ايضا كوري في
تعاونتك في علاقه نوعيه مختلفه جدا وهذا
نعتقد ايضا ستكون هناك مرحله اخرى لبناء
تحقيق هذه المنظومه قد نشهد زيارات الامير
خالد لدول اخرى للتوسع في هذا المجال
وبناء شراكات شراكات دفاعيه متينه وتحقق
المملكه استقرارها الامني والناس شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه الاراء المفيده السيد
جاسر الجاسر شكرا
في السعوديه دشنت وزاره الشؤون البلديه
والقرويه والاسكان معرض ريستيكس الرياض
العقاري 2023 الذي يعد اهم ملتقى سنوي
لصنع القرار في القطاع العقاري والاستثمار
الاسكاني والتمويلي وشهد المعرض الذي من
المقرر ان يستمر حتى العاشر من الشهر
الجاري اطلاق اربعه صناديق عقاريه بقيمه
اجماليه تجاوزت اربعه مليارات ريال بهدف
توفير اكثر من 4000 وحده سكنيه في كل من
الرياض والمدينه المنوره على مساحه تتجاوز
مليون متر مربع
بحضور اكثر من 100 منظمه دوليه واقليميه
انطلقت اعمال مؤتمر مستقبل منظمات التربيه
والثقافه والعلوم تحت شعار مع النحو
التغيير في القرن ال 21 في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياضه ويحدث المؤتمر الذي
تنظمه المنظمه العربيه للتربيه والثقافه
والعلوم الالكسو واللجنه الوطنيه السعوديه
للتربيه والثقافه والعلوم الى تعزيز
التعاون والاستدامه بين المنظمات الدوليه
اضافه الى بناء منصه عالميه حاضنه
للمنظمات الدوليه
ومن الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الواحد الحميد اهلا بك عبد الواحد يعني
بدات فعاليات المؤتمر ماذا في جلسات اليوم
ومن هم ابرز المتحدثين
اهلا وسهلا بك راويه نعم نحن في اليوم
الاول من هذا المؤتمر الذي يضم اكثر من 65
متحدثا اضافه الى ذلك اكثر من 100 منظمه
تشارك في هذا المؤتمر الذي يقام لاول مره
اليوم الاول يضم عديد من الجلسات وحلقات
النقاش التي تتناول موضوعات مختلفه متعلقه
بالمحاور الرئيسيه لهذا المؤتمر الذي يقام
على مدار يومين طبعا في هذا المؤتمر هناك
العديد من خبراء الدوليين الذين يشاركون
في جلسات هذا المؤتمر على مدار اليوم
لنتحدث اكثر حول تفاصيل هذا المؤتمر ينضم
الينا الاستاذ هاني المقبل وهو رئيس
المجلس التنفيذي للالكس واهلا وسهلا بك
استاذ هاني نريد ان نعرف يعني ما هي
المخرجات المتوقعه من هذا المؤتمر
اول شيء شكرا القناه العربيه خلنا نتكلم
اليوم انه التاريخ اليوم سجل اعتباره من
ثمانيه مارس 2023 هذه هي اول تجمع يجمع
المنظمات الدوليه والاقليميه المهتمه
بالتربيه الثقافه العلوم لاكثر من خمسين
عاما لم تشتمها منظمات تحت مظله واحده
لمناقشه سبل مستقبل توجهاتها اليوم بدات
هذا الحراك وهذا التواصل واتوقع ان
مخرجاته اكثر كثير مما توقع هناك مقوله
انجليزيه تقول بان الحوارات الصحيه ده
عاده تنتج منتجات عظيمه اليوم ما شاهدناه
من تقارب الافكار والرؤى المشتركه بين
المنظمات والتوجهاتها يعطينا امل بان
المستقبل في التنسيق والتعاون والتكامل
سيكون اكبر بكثير من مكان في السابق اليوم
هذه المنظمات تخدم الدول وتخدم الافراد
لكن عملها في السابق كان احادي الاطراف
لكن اليوم هو سينتقل يكون ثنائي بتنسيق
مشترك وتعاون ولا يمكن ان تتحقق رؤيه
دوليه مشتركه ما لم يكن هناك تواصل وتنسيق
وتواصل ثاني خبراء يعني يشاركون في هذا
المؤتمر الذي يقام لاول مره على الاطلاق
ماذا تتوقعون مستقبلا في هذا الاطار
خلني اتكلم بس ان اليوم هذه مبادره من
المنظمه العربيه للاكسو والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وافقت مشكوره باستضافه كريمه على
استضافه هذا المؤتمر
كيف يتحول هذا المؤتمر الى حوار عملي في
المستقبل بناء على الحراك والنقاش اللي تم
بين المنظمات سيعطي امل كبير في فتح قنوات
كثيره القنوات لا يمكن ان تتحقق وكل يعمل
في مكتبه اليوم اكثر من 100 منظمه موجوده
في الرياض اكثر من 70 متحدث من مختلف من
سبع قطاعات تقريبا كلها تتكلم على
المستقبل مستقبل لا يعني
الحديث عن التفاصيل وانهم يعني الحديث عن
الفرس اليوم هناك فرص كبيره جدا موجوده في
التعاون وفي الاخير ما يخدم البشريه هو ما
سينتج عن هذه العلاقات والتواصل والشراكات
بين المنظمات شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
التفاصيل استاذ هاني المقبل على كل هذه
التفاصيل التي زودنا بها متعلقه بالمؤتمر
طبعا المؤتمر راويه يستمر على مدار يومين
نحن في اليوم الاول اليوم الثاني سوف يعني
يكون هناك العديد من الجلسات
لهذا المؤتمر عبد الواحد الحميد اذا مراسل
العربيه من الرياض شكرا جزيلا لك
بعد ان تجاوز اجماليه تبرعات عبر منصه
احسان حاجز الثلاثه مليارات ريال سعودي
خلال عامين كرم امير منطقه الرياض الامير
فيصل بن بندر نيابه عن ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان كرم يوم امس كبار
المانحين والمتبرعين عبر منصه احسان التي
استفاد منها نحو خمسه ملايين مستفيده وفي
السياق جاء ذلك او خلال هذا التكريم
الاعلان عن فتح باب التبرعات لمشروع
السلام الوقفي بالمدينه المنوره فضلا عن
تدشين بوابه جديده تعنى بكبار المحسنين في
منصه احسن
نشره الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تسعه ايام عن الفورميلون في السعوديه
اكتمال جاهزيه حلبه جده وعروض ترفيهيه
مصاحبه للزوار
اهلا بكم من جديد الى شمال غرب سوريا وصلت
نحو 20 عياده طبيه متنقله مقدمه من مركز
الملك سلمان للعيادات وتقدم خدمات طبيه
لمتضر الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا
وتركيا نتابع التفاصيل في تقرير مراسلنا
محمد الاشقر
تاثر القطاع الصحي بشكل مباشر نتيجه
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وانعكس ذلك على المرضى الذين يعانون من
امراض مزمنه ويصنفون كحالات بارده
ويحتاجون لرعايه دوريه كهذه المسنه في
ناحيه جنديرس التي تعاني من امراض مزمنه
تضم العيادات المتنقله اطباء وممرضين
وصيادله يعملون على تقديم مختلف الخدمات
الطبيه والادويه المجانيه لمحتاجيها اضافه
لاحاله الحالات الحرجه الى المستشفيات
الخدمات الصحيه العم قدمها هي خدمات رعايه
صحيه اولي بتشمل الكشف الطبي الفحص الطبي
ايضا تقديم الادويه اللازمه للعلاج بشكل
مجاني بالاضافه الى ذلك عم نشتغل على
الجانب التغذوي على حالات سوء التخزين قدم
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والتنميه نحو 20
عياده متنقله تقدم خدماتها في المناطق
التي اصابها الزلزال شمال غربي سوريا
ويتركز عمل هذه العيادات في المخيمات
ومراكز الايواء المستحدثه
ما بين منطقه ادلب وعفرين طبعا هاي عيلات
عم يتم او عم تستجيب لمراكز اللواء
المؤقته التي تم العمل عليها من قبل فرقنا
في داخل السوري عم يتم القيام بعمليه
الفحوصات الطبيه والصرف الادويه اضافي الى
نظام الاحالات اللي وفرته الفرق او من
عيارات المتنقله بالتنسيق وتعاون الصحيه
لم تعجبن منطقه الليبي عفرين تخفف
العيادات المتنقله من معاناه المرضى
والمتضررين من الزلزال شمالي سوريا توفر
العيادات المتنقله عده خدمات طبيه وتعتبر
استجابه للظروف الصعبه التي فرضها الزلزال
المدمر وحلا اسعافيا للسكان في ظل خروج
معظم المشافي والنقاط الطبيه عن الخدمه في
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال محمد الاشقر
العربيه شمال سوريا
ننتقل لمشاهدينا لنشاهد هذه الصور من
المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك الذي يجمع الرئيس
الاوكراني مع امين عام الامم المتحده
انطونيو خلال زيارته الثالثه الى اكياف
طبعا الرئيس زيلينسكي يتحدث وكان انطونيو
قد اعتبر بانه وذكر بانه ازمه الحبوب على
ازمه الحبوب هي على قائمه واجنده
المحادثات التي تجمعه وهناك اتفاق على
تمديد اتفاقيه الحبوب
اذا هذه ليست الزياره الاولى لانطونيو
غوتورش الى كيف كما ذكرنا هي الثالثه منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب مع دخولها عامها الثاني
الى جده غرب السعوديه حيث تنطلق في 17 من
مارس الجاري بطوله سباق جائزه السعوديه
الكبرى للفرمولا 1 للعام الجاريث 2023
البطوله المقرر اقامتها في حلبه انهت
استعداداتها النهائيه لاستقبال المتسابقين
للموسم الثالث تواليا ومن المقرر ان تشهد
المنافسات اقامه فعاليات مصاحبه تتضمن
مجموعه متنوعه من العروض الترفيهيه
والحفلات الموسيقيه الحيه وغيرها من
الفعاليات
ومن جده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سعود
الخلف اهلا بك سعود يعني انقل لنا الاجواء
والاعدادات من عندك
انا الراوي ان اتواجد الان داخل الحلبه
كورنيش جدا والتي هي على اهبه الاستعداد
لاستقبال الحدث الرياضي والترفيهي الاضخم
في تاريخ المملكه حيث تنطلق يعني خلال
الايام القادمه فعاليات سباق جائزه
السعوديه الكبرى
لعام 2023 وطبعا هذه الاستضافه للمره
الثالثه خلال مده قصيره تعكس النجاح
الكبير راويه للقطاع للقطاع الرياضه
المحركات في المملكه في اطار دعم غير
المحدود من قبل خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان وولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان وتوجيه وثقه وزير الرياضه الامير
عبد العزيز بن تركي الفيصل نعم راويه نعم
سعود يعني متى سينطلق السباق بمعنى ماذا
سيحصل في اليوم الاول والثاني
طبعا ساترك الكاميرا تتجول وانا يعني
اعطيك الاجابه الفعاليات ستنطلق بعد ظهر
يوم الجمعه في السابع عشر من مارس حيث
ينتلئ 20 سائق من نجوم الفورمولا 1 الى
سياراتهم في حصتين للتجارب الحره لمده
ساعه واحده ويوم السبت ينتقل السائقين الى
المسار مره اخرى
لخوض حصه التجارب الاخيره طبعا لمده ساعه
واحده اليها الجوله التاهيليه في تمام
الساعه الثامنه مساء وستحدد هذه الجوله
التي تمتد على مدار ساعه كامله شكل شبكه
الانطلاق للسباق الرئيسي يوم الاحد حيث
يتم تصنيف السائقين وفقا لاسرع وقت وفي
تمام الساعه الثامنه من مساء يوم الاحد
التاسع عشر من مارس سينطلق افضل السائقين
في العالم من شبكه الانطلاق يتسابقون لمده
تصل الى ساعتين او 50 لفه لتحديد الفائز
بصباط جائزه السعوديه
الكبرى للفورمول لعام
2003 ماذا عن الفعاليات الترفيهيه سعود
المصاحبه لهذا السباق
بالتاكيد هنالك فعاليات كثيره هذه
الفعاليات عديده من الانشطه انشطه سباقات
على الحلبه الى جانب فعاليات الرئيسيه مثل
سباقي الدعم وتحدي بورشا سبرنت الشرق
الاوسط وبطوله العالم للفورميلا 2 كما
ايضا توفر كره الجمهور مزيجا من تجربه
والعديد من الانشطه الممتعه والترفيهيه
والحماسيه اللي تلائم جميع افراد العائله
للاستمتاع بعطله نهايه الاسبوع وايضا من
العروض الترفيهيه حفلات موسيقيه حيه
يحييها نخبه من المع نجوم الغناء العالمي
طبعا هذه هي كما ذكرنا الفعاليات واود ان
اذكر معلومه جميله جدا اذا ذهبت الكاميرا
الان
تم تلوين الارضيه في الفورميلا 1
بمسابقه اعلن عنها قبل تقريبا ثلاثه الى
اشهر دخل الى هذه المسابقه 250 فنان وحصلت
فنانه على فرصه ان ترسم
التراث السعودي بشكل حضاري وبشكل يعني
يعرف الناس على الثقافه السعوديه هنا على
يساري مرسومه الجمال وفي الخلف مرسومه
الرواشين التي تزين مدينه جده شكرا جزيلا
لك اذا من جده مراسل العربيه سعود الخلف
اذا نذهب لنشاهد هذه الصور
لمظاهرات تحولت الى اشتباكات بين قوات
الامن اليونانيه ومتظاهرين على خلفيه
حادثه القطارين التي يعني خلفت قتلى منذ
قرابه الاسبوع
طبعا كان هناك حديث اليوم لوزير النقل
اليوناني انه بلاد قد تستانف تسير قطارات
الركاب بنهايه هذا الشهر شهر مارس ولكن
بعد تامين وتوفير اجراءات السلامه
التامه اذا نشاهد هذه الصور
للاشتباكات بين المتظاهرين
والشرطه اليونانيه
[موسيقى]
نذكر بانه حادث اصطدام القطارين هو الاكثر
دمويه في سجل حوادث القطارات باليونان
وبعد دخل موظفوا موظفي السكك الحديديه
باضراب
يتجدد كل 24 ساعه
عاشت المراه السعوديه سنوات
ذهبيه خلال الفتره الماضيه من خلال
التشريعات والتمكين المستمر في قطاعات عده
الزميله العنود العبدلي تعطينا لمحه عن
تمكين السعوديه
عصر
ذهبي تعيشه المراه السعوديه على جميع
الاصعده تمكين المستمر وقفزات نوعيه
ومناصب قياديه تولتها السيدات السعوديات
خلال سنوات الماضيه خمس سيدات سعوديات
هن الاميره ريما بنت بندر بن سلطان سفيره
المملكه في واشنطن وهي اول سفيره سعوديه
في عام 2019 بعد ذلك عينت امال المعلمه
سفيره للسعوديه لدى النرويج وايناس
الشهوان سفيره لدى السويد واخيرا شهد سلك
الدبلوماسي ايضا مشاهدينا انضمام سفيرتين
نسرين الشبل سفيره لدى فنلندا وهيفا جديع
رئيسه للبعثه السعوديه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وعلى صعيد التمكين الداخلي
مشاهدينا بلغ معدل المشاركه الاقتصاديه
للسعوديات 37 في المئه في الربع الثالث
لعام 2022
مقارنه ب 17% في عام
في حين تضاعفت حصه المراه في سوق العمل
الى نحو
35% في الربع الثالث لعام 2022
متجاوزه بذلك مستهدف الرؤيه لعام 2030
للوصول الى نسبه 30% كما وصلت مشاهدينا
نسبه السعوديات في المناصب الاداريه
المتوسطه والعليا لواحد واربعين وعشرين في
المئه خلال الربع الثالث لعام 2020
مارس 2018 اصدر فيه قرار مشاركه المراه
السعوديه في سلك العسكري وفي شهر سبتمبر
2021 شهيه السعوديات او شهدت السعوديه حفل
تخريج اول دفعه من مركز تدريب الكادر
النسائي للقوات المسلحه السعوديه لمختلف
الرتب العسكريه تمكين المستمر للسعوديات
في كافه القطاعات
وبالحديث عن تمكين السيدات السعوديات في
القطاع العسكري نتوقف مع هذا التقرير الذي
عايش مجندات وزاره الدفاع السعوديه في
التدريب واثناء التخرج هاني الصفيان
والتفاصيل
خطوات ثابته وصف واحد مئات الفتيات
السعوديات يتقلدن رتبا عسكريه في وزاره
الدفاع السعوديه بعد اتمام التدريب برا
وبحرا وجوا
[موسيقى]
الان انا ضابطه صف في القوات البحريه
واطمح مستقبلا ان شاء الله اني اكون في
احدى السفن التابعه للجلات الملك للقوات
البحريه طبعا حنا انا وزميلاتي في القوات
البحريه يعني كلنا ذوق قدره وذو معرفه
ونستطيع ان شاء الله نوصل لهذا المكان
اللي احنا نطمح له باذن الله ابتداء برفع
العلم باستخدام السلاح وتطبيق النظريات
العسكريه وليس انتهاء باداء القسم استطاعت
المجندات السعوديه مقاومه الكثير من
العقبات في هذا المركز التدريبي تمهيدا
لمستقبلهن العسكري ان شاء الله نكون قدها
وعسكريات مثل اعلى لخدمه الوطن على صوره
كامله باذن الله شعور جدا جميل فخوره جدا
اني انا اكون في هذا المكان امارس مهنتي
وفي نفس الوقت قعد امارس حلم فعلا كنت
احلم فيه اني انا اكون بهذا المكان طبعا
المجتمع ينظر للمراه دخول السلك العسكري
بالفخر والاعتزاز بفضل ولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان حفظ الله ورعايته الوظائف
العسكريه التي وفرتها السعوديه للفتيات
ساعدت في شغل متطلبات يحتاجها القطاعان
العسكري والامني مثل عمليات المراقبه
والحمايه داخل المقرات العسكريه وخارجها
هانس فيان العربيه الرياض
الى اخبار الرياضه مع زياد عبيدات
[موسيقى]
شكرا راويه واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
يخوض لناصر بقياده اللاعب البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو اصعب اختبار لصدارته
للدوري السعودي لكره القدم عندما يحل ضيفا
على الاتحاد صاحب المركز الثاني وصاحب
اقوى دفاع في المسابقه غدا الخميس ضمن
الجوله العشرين ويتصدر ان نصل المسابقه ب
46 نقطه وامريكا الفريق اقوى هجوم ب 42
هدفا ويعتبر ثاني اقوى دفاع بعد الاتحاد
وسيغيب معنا نصر متصدر قائمه الهدافين
اللاعب البرازيلي تاليسكا للاصابه بينما
سيقود هجوم الاتحاد اللاعب المغربي عبد
الرزاق حمد الله ثاني الهدافين 12 هدفا
وكان نادي الاتحاد قد تغلب على النصر
بثلاثيه في شهر يناير الماضي ضمن الدوري
نصف النهائي لمسابقه كاس السوبر السعوديه
في ايابي دور 16 لمسابقه دوري ابطال
اوروبا لكره القدم يلتقي الليله باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي مع مضيفه بايرن ميونخ
الالمانيه وكان نادي البافاريق تغلب ذها
على نظيره الفرنسي بهدف دون مقابل
وسيفتقد النادي الفرنسي لخدمته لاعبه
البرازيلي نيمار بسبب الاصابه بينما يعتمد
على الثنائي
وميسي للعوده بالنتيجه والتاهل
قرات الجدل المثار حول غياب نيمار انها
اصابه مؤسفه وضربه للفريق نعم الفريق
سيكون اكثر توازنا ولكن لا يمكن ان نقول
اننا افضل دون نيمار لانه حل هجومي مهم
للغايه لكل خطه النقاط قوه وضعف يجب ان
نكون اكثر شراسه حينها يمكن القول بان
لدينا فرصه للتاهل المباراه لن تكون سهله
بل سنواجه فريقا كبيرا مر عليه العديد من
النجوم سواء السابقين والحاليين واعتاد
دائما منافسه على لقب دوري الابطال يجب ان
نضغط من الاعلى ونستعيد الكره في اسرع وقت
ممكن لاننا نسعى للفوز بكل المباريات
والمنافسه على دوري الابطال هدف واضح
لاداره النادي لكن في النهايه سيكون هناك
فريق فائز واخر مهزوم مباراه بايرن ميونخ
لن تكون فاصله في موسم باريس لاننا فريق
يلعب تحت ضغط المنافسه للفوز بكل البطولات
نعاني بالفعل من ازمه الدفاعيه وعلينا
تصحيحها استقبلنا مؤخرا عددا من الاهداف
ونبهت على اللاعبين بضروره توخي الحذر
ولكن المنافس لديه نقاط ضعف ايضا
سيبدا اساسيا وهذا سيغير الكثير عما حدث
في الذهب فهو من افضل المهاجمين في العالم
ولديه اسلحه مذهله لذا يجب علينا مواجهته
ككتله واحده لا اظن ان ساديو مانيه سيشارك
في تشكيله الاساسيه لكننا لم نتخذ قرارنا
بعد لازال بامكانه صناعه الفارق معنا حاله
مشاركته كبديل اذا لم يشارك اساسيا حضرنا
جيدا للفوز عليهم نريد تسجيل الاهداف دون
التركيز على تفاصيل الاخرى
ومن جانبه اكمل نادي ميلان الايطالي
تحضيراته لملاقاه توتنهام الانجليزيه في
اياب دور ال16 المسابقه دوري ابطال اوروبا
وعيش الفريقان فتره ليست بالمثاليه محليا
حيث تراجع فريق المدرب ستيفانو بيولي الى
المركز الخامس في الدوري الايطاليه بعد
الخساره الاخيره امام فيورنتينا وسيدخل
توتنهام المباراه بعد خسارتين على التوالي
ونجح الفريق الايطالي بالفوز ذهابا بهدف
وحيد
وبدوره عاد المدرب الايطالي انطونيو كونتي
لقياده تدريبات نادي توتنهام استعدادا
لاستضافه ميلان في دوري الابطال وكان
كونتي قد بقي في ايطاليا بعد مباراه
الذهاب بتعليمات من الاطباء لاستكمال
تعافيهم من عمليه جراحيه اجراها في نهايه
شهر يناير الماضي
المدرب على مقاعد البدلاء مهم دائما دون
شك سيمثل كونتي القيمه المضافه من خلال
تواجده لكن في كافه الاحوال نحن نواجه
منافسا صعبا سيكون مستعدا ومتحفزا للغايه
نتوقع ان يضع توتنهام حامل الكره تحت
المزيد من الضغط مقارنه بما فعلناه في
ميلانو اعتقد انهم سيكونون اقوياء اذا
نظرت لارقام توتنهام تحديدا في الشوط
الثاني فهم فريق قوي للغايه يجب ان نكون
حذرين اثناء مواجهتهم
تاهل الشرقه الى الدور نصف النهائي
لمسابقه كاس الرئيس دوله الامارات لكره
القدم بعد تغلبه على الجزيره بهدفين مقابل
هدف واحد في الدور ربع النهائي من البطوله
سجل الشارقه عن طريق الوان فيريرا في
الوقت بدل الضائع لشوط الاول
وكايولوكس في الوقت بدل ضاع لشوط الثاني
فيما سجل فلورين هدف الجزيره الوحيد في
الدقيقه التاسعه والخمسين وبذلك سيلتقي
الشارقه مع عجمان في الدور قبل النهائي من
هذه المسابقه
تعادل الوداد مع مضيفه نهضه بركان بثلاثه
اهداف لكل منهما في مباراه مؤجله من
الجوله التاسع عشره للدوري المغربي لكره
القدم سجل بوليس سامبو اولا للفريق الاحمر
فيما ادرك البحري التعادل لاصحاب الارض في
هذه المباراه وفي الشوط الثاني منح ايمن
الحسوني التقدم من جديد لفريق الوداد وفي
الوقت المحتسب بعد الاضائع تمكنت دايو من
تسجيل هدفين لفريق نهضه بركان وفي الدقيقه
الثالثه عشر من الوقت المحتسب بادل الضائع
احرز امينه فرحان هدف التعادل للوداد
يرتفع رصيد الوداد الى 39 نقطه في المركز
الثاني بينما وصلت حاصله نهضه بركان الى
28 نقطه في المركز السادس للدوري المغربي
لكره القدم
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك راويه
[موسيقى]
شكرا زياد خلال هذه الايام تدخل مرحله
الامطار الصيفيه وتسمى عند العامه امطار
المراويح التفاصيل في تقويم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تقع جل البلدان العربيه في المنطقه
الواقعه بين مدار السرطان ومدار الجدي
وهذه البقعه تتعامد عليها الشمس طوال فتره
الصيف فالحراره اصل في اجوائها صيفا
والبروده مستورده من خارجها شتاء عبر
الرياح الشماليه والخريف يولد من رحم
الصيف ولاده طبيعيه والربيع يولد من رحم
الشتاء ولاده متعسره اي انه موسم التقلبات
الجويه الحاده فرياحه جالبه للغبار
والاتربه وامطاره مشوبه بحبات براد وقصف
رعده واوميض برق مهلكه للحرث والنسل
وبانتهاء موسم الربيع نهجر الاجواء
الجميله واللطيفه بناظرك الفتان امنت
بالسحر وهل بعد امام الصبابه من كفر فلا
تعتمد بالهدر قتل متيم فان المنايا لا
تزيد
عن الهجري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وخلال هذه الايام تدخل علينا مرحله
الامطار الصيفيه وهي امطار تتشكل محليا
وهطولها يكون في بقعه دون ثانيه وتسمى
عندنا عند العامه بامطار المراويه واهل
الخليج يسمونها بالسرايات وعاده ما تكون
مسبوقه بعصف ريح ان الحليمه اذا ثارت
حميته مثل العواصف لا تبقي
ولا تذروا
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابع الى العناوين
ز
معارك بخمو
يؤكد ان الحلف لا يستبعد سقوطها بيد
الروسي قريبا
زخم سياسي ودبلوماسي لقائه سعوديه يمنيه
بولنديه في الرياض وتاكيد على الاستقرار
العالمي
الرياض تجمع مئه منظمه استشراف واقع
التعليم والثقافه ودعوات لتكامل ثقافي
عالمي
الحمد لله انكم تكونوا
شهر كامل على الكارثه عيادات مركز الملك
سلمان تواصل اغاثه متضرر الزلزال شمال
سوريا
تمكين مستمر للسيدات السعوديات الرابعه
تعيش مجندات وزاره الدفاع من التدريب الى
التخرج
الى اللقاء